[Music]
Sam Holtz was 12 years old when he won
ESPN's 2015 March Madness bracket
challenge I had the best bracket out of
eleven point five seven million people
what if we told you this bracketology
prodigy doesn't even watch college
basketball before the tournament I
really don't watch any college
basketball
this time last year
young Sammy was filling out his winning
n-c-double-a tournament bracket along
with millions of other Americans Sam
what was your strategy for success well
I just filled out who I think is gonna
win
was there a science to your picks now
it's just pick whoever you want to win
there's no science just that simple hmm
maybe Sammy's mom has an idea I think he
was lucky all right let's take a closer
look at some of Sammy's predictions why
pick 11 seed UCLA to make the sweet 16
because I visited their campus and I
really liked their College or seven seed
Michigan State to make the Final Four
Tom Izzo the coach Italian and I'm kind
of Italian - so or Wisconsin - upset
then undefeated Kentucky it kind of gets
boring to watch the same team win and
win every year in and wanted to see to
do that you must really love basketball
I'm more of a baseball football guy
baseball is my main sport how is this
possible I mean what are the chances of
filling out a perfect bracket we
consulted bracket expert Mike Magazine
somewhere in one in some number of
quintillions thanks professor magazine
any advice for the millions of Americans
you'll probably beat out again this year
just pick who you think is gonna win and
go with your gut remind us why we should
listen to you because I want to last
year there you have it
pick the schools you visited don't
listen to the experts and don't watch
any college basketball and you too can
reach the promised land just like Sammy
Holtz
[Music]
you
[Music]